[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's up it's us again and it's episode
57 yeah
rolling by yeah I'm not 67 yeah I know
it's on spontaneous human combustion yes
this was this was also a request
actually most of the topics that are
coming up for the next few months of
pretty much all requests yeah but this
one was actually I was kind of like oh I
don't know if I want to do one on that
but actually the more I looked into it
the kind of more fun it seemed yeah I
mean you know as fun as a person
spontaneously catching on fire can be
not so fun for the person involved but
you know what I mean it's kind of it'll
be a kind of a fun topic I think but
before we do that let's do our usual
shout outs first thing we want to do is
thank our newest patreon patrons yeah we
have four new ones for new ones
Joseph Samantha Sondra and Tara thank
you guys very much
yeah it's awesome to show the girl one
yeah yeah and oh and I also want to tell
the the $20 and up patrons that you
should be receiving stuff from us like
very soon I mailed out you know some
free swag like a one of my novels and
sticker and stuff like that yeah to
women yeah and I mailed that out a
couple of days ago so you should be
getting that if you haven't gotten it
already when I was going to England
though that might take a little bit
longer yeah they said it would take a
long time but but it is mailed so just
keep an eye out for that also
spooky Empire coming up at the end of
October man a swine I know right that's
why I really have to prepare for that
more I mean I have like a some
preparation done but not really
we got a stock unseen handbooks just to
sell there these things are huge yeah
they really are there well this was the
first time that I had like a print copy
in my little hands
so I didn't realize how big how big they
are which is good but well speaking of
fat books also my new true crime book
the faceless villain another big one is
yeah it's gonna be about the same size
and actually I finished writing it yeah
like three days ago so all I'm doing now
I'm working on the print layout and I
have to re-record some of the audio
cuz I added some stuff later on and
edited a little bit so but the print and
the e-book should be up in a couple of
weeks I would think yeah the audio it
takes so gonna take a little bit longer
because remember the approval process of
that yeah yeah that takes like usually
that takes about ten days like once you
upload it because you have to upload
what you have to do is you have to
upload at least the print version first
and then that takes 24 to 48 hours to go
live and then the print version has to
be for sale before you can even upload
the audio version yeah and then once the
audio version is uploaded then they have
to it has to go through audibles quality
control like they have to listen to it
and stuff like that yeah and there's not
much once audios approve who will get
out some free copies do you guys yeah
cuz yeah they'll give me some audio
codes and if you guys aren't one you can
have one so that'll be that'll probably
be October sometime yeah I think but
hopefully I know Cassandra and Australia
will want one yeah yeah I had a good
time writing this book actually you know
it's just gonna be it's volume 1 so
volume 2 should be out sometime next
year hopefully but spring him next year
I should have volume 2 out but other
than that oh and we also did another
movie review we did predator yeah if you
didn't see that so that's up and we've
also done should we say no no just let
that one hit just let it drop like a
bomb BAM
you'll see it they'll see that they'll
see that the title card you did and
they'll go yeah yeah that's right yeah
it's a promised episode yes and we
finally got around it and we think it's
our best one so far I think I do alright
so we're talking about spontaneous human
combustion yeah
okay now here's the thing about
spontaneous human combustion I kind of
feel like that it's sort of seen as a
paranormal phenomenon but I don't know
it's weird because there's like a
distinction if you're gonna say it's a
paranormal phenomenon then basically the
only distinction that you make is that
while the fire came from somewhere
inside the person right because
obviously people burn up all the time
like not all the time but you know
like it does happen and you know and
there are photos to prove it which I
will put in the YouTube video so sorry
if anyone screaming shut there's some
kind of Christmas episode I remember
when I was a kid when I first heard of
this you know before we really kind of
understood it to the level I understand
now I always pictured it as being some
kind of chemical process or some kind of
chemical error happening inside the
human metabolism you know I mean it
starts a fire yeah that's all right you
know and if the person burns up in a
flash yeah and some of the witness
testimony evidently and I always notice
from the eighteen hundred's ones that I
remember here here is that the person
did just come first into flames right
but it's difficult to know are they
talking about somebody backing up into a
candle or what exactly yeah we'll see
the thing about the thing about it is
that even if it was some kind of
chemical process happening inside the
human body like that doesn't sound
totally crazy no like that sounds like
it can totally happen yeah well this so
your metabolism burns calories right is
heat right or chemicals inside the body
right yeah obviously so I'm not saying
that that's like a totally so I can
understand like why you know people
would have that perception that that
could happen because you know it's not a
crazy thing the problem of those is the
body's mostly water and water doesn't
burn right you know people will feel
better about this but human beings are
really not all that Flamm know they're
hard to burn you need to accelerate get
pour gasoline on them or something like
that well yeah and I mean obviously if
you know clothes catch on fire yeah and
body itself and usually I've seen videos
of people douse themselves with gas and
and set themselves on fire like in India
they did I did somehow protesters yeah
yeah or maybe it wasn't India maybe it
was too bad or something yeah it was
Tibetan monks and they're famous dude it
was gross and then too did not burn up
yeah he caught on fire and walked around
like he was trying to talk to people
with his skin just snapping off of it
like a yeah rubberband back but his skin
falling off man it will see now and I
even though the fire went out he was
alive standing there yeah just like a
skin
well I think that this is why this is
the reason why some people think that
there's like some kind of paranormal
thing going on is because one when you
cremate a human body basically you have
to put that sucker in the oven at like
at least 1500 degrees for a couple of
hours and even then there's still bone
fragments left that they have to smush
up and everything like that and you know
and that's best
specially designed for that and also
firefighters will tell you that when
they go in and you know have to get
bodies out of burned houses and stuff
like that that the bodies are still
recognizable as human body so the reason
that there became a thing about
spontaneous human combustion being weird
is because I mean if you see the
pictures of some of the crime scenes and
stuff like that they do look very
strange because sometimes okay one you
can't usually tell that there was a
person it usually just looks kind of
like a pile of ashes with like feet
sticking at feet and like the legs and
feet are not burned every now and then
like a skull yeah and sometimes and I
don't know if this happens in every one
and but I have snow skull well I've seen
in two instances that the skull was
shrunken right yeah from heat so what's
weird is that the room shows signs of
smoke damage and intense heat but it
never bursts into fine but the whole
house doesn't burn it out which seems
very strange to be the bed or the chair
wherever the box so I can see why people
would think that this was a weird
phenomenon because it does look weird
the crime scenes do look weird and even
if you know if you watch like I watched
like a [ __ ] ton of documentaries on it
and I was reading about it even
firefighters you know who've been doing
this 30 40 years and have seen all kinds
of horrible things even they will say
it's very weird looking yeah like
because normally if somebody catches on
fire their clothes catch on fire
something like that usually it would
burn the house down or something like
that yeah I remember seeing like
documentaries on America the 70s and I
was a little kid and they're showing
pictures of it describe this remember
this when I first found out about this
yeah it was kind of like owning in the
search of type program yeah things like
that you don't really see those
kind of programs too much anymore at
least not the one from the 70s yeah but
the ones from the seventies were real
lurid well yeah from from memory yeah
and you know like I said I I remember I
think I had um it might have been one of
those like Reader's Digest like
mysterious universe type of books or
something like that and it had the very
famous picture of like this little pile
of ashes like one little foot sticking
out with a shoe still yeah and that
seems like a very common image for like
human spontaneous combustion because
that you know the body is reduced so
obviously this fire you know is hugely
hot but somehow doesn't ignite other
things so the thing about spontaneous
human combustion at first there are
cases of it like reported cases of it
going back to you know probably the
1400s I think like that but it wasn't
really called spontaneous human
combustion until like the 1740s around
1746 someone named Paul Rowley he
published an article in a lake in a
journal called Philosophical
Transactions and he coined the term then
later on you know there were all these
different cases of it and stuff like
that now probably it got it kind of took
off in popularity the concept of
spontaneous human combustion after
Charles Dickens
killed off one of his characters in the
novel Bleak House using spontaneous
combustion the the character he was kind
of a bad guy and his name was crook with
a k' yeah you know evidently he was a
drunk and his stomach like just caught
him like he bursts into flames like out
of his stomach and just burned up and
someone saw it so that's kind of where
that came from now I should add that
right around this time period I mean
Mark Twain also killed off a character
that way there was other Washington
Irving stuff like that there was a
perception that spontaneous human
combustion happened to drunks yeah what
it does right so people like I said so
that's not a crazy thanks they think oh
well alcohol is flammable so if you
pickle yourself in enough eventually
although it should be said that this and
it is kind of a myth it's a myth but it
did come from the temperance movement
because they were trying to scare people
in a not driving so basically they're
saying you better not drink too much or
you're gonna burst into flames
remember reading I remember hearing from
our issue I remember reading and some of
the old literature that I read is that
there was a correlation between old
people overweight people and people that
consumed alcohol that they would fall
victims to spontaneously now that is
Trail and you're right
once you kind of understand what
spontaneous human combustion is and what
mechanisms happen you see how that
that's likely and that increases the
likelihood that it could happen yeah how
different means it's usually and this is
kind of like the British Medical Journal
didn't did an article about it in that
30 is the late 30s and they basically
point now they said that this is not
spontaneous human combustion ie
the person is not bursting into flames
from within sure hello looks like it but
it does look like it but they said that
there are certain characteristics of
these types of cases the victims are
usually alcoholics or are in poor health
diabetics things of that nature they're
usually old yeah and they're usually fat
and floors yeah they're usually smokers
you know they have limited mobility or
and things like that now they say the
bodies look like now usually the hands
and feet fall off or the extremities are
not burned usually the middle part of
the body is burned and things that are
close by the body that you think would
catch fire do not catch fire right and
like I said that's one thing that's very
strange if you look at let it the you
know the scene photos from spontaneous
human combustion cases that you know
there's this little pile of ash with
feet sticking out and then nothing is
really burned around it although
sometimes there will be heat damage like
a but like things will melt and stuff of
that stuff like that
oh and usually to the the room that
it'll just everything will have like a
greasy yeah kitsch which you know what
that is done right that's your that's
your fat like it all over everything
that's like super gross bacon grease yes
bacon grease it yeah so going back to
like I said probably the first recorded
case of spontaneous human combustion
quote-unquote was from the 1400s that
happened in Italy and is supposedly a
knight and he was at a party one night
he was drinking some excuse me he was
drinking some wine and he had drank
a bit like I don't think it was
over-the-top or anything like that but
he had drunk quite a bit of wine and
evidently everyone at the party said he
suddenly just burst into flames yeah
I've read about this right there was
another one later on in the 1700s and
this was actually a countess
her name was cornelia to bandy and she
was evidently going from her bed to the
window and somehow in between those two
locations she burst into flames and
there was nothing left except the bottom
of her legs and her fingers and
everything else was just I used to have
this big book I think was called
mysteries of the unexplained and it was
pretty fat book I don't really remember
who the author was but it was a
compilation of a bunch of different
cases and they had a whole section on
spontaneous human combustion and there
were a lot of them in the 1800s that
were described oh they're had a party
and then a guy just burst into flames
and the flames come out of his stomach
or his side or his back in a jet like a
jeddak burning gas yeah and then the
person whirls around and people try to
save him but he's just consumed in a
bunch of ashes you know fly up in the
air and it's boom it's you know it's
like something out of a science fiction
movie yeah but you don't really know
what they're talking about you can't
prove it did this really happen it has
an unsubstantiated report did this guy
back into a candle you know which seems
very likely to me especially back in the
days before electricity because there
were like candles and fireplaces
everywhere right and I don't know if you
guys know but those things like shoot
embers out yeah if you walk too close to
as an era of yellow journalism that too
newspapers would write anything yes
they've just straight-up lied they were
seeing airships would come down and
throw anchors down onto the ground and
guys would you know crawl down the whole
town saw and everyone in San Francisco
saw giant air bus with men yelling down
and you know there were no airships yeah
back in eighteen and you know they're
describing Zeppelin's yeah but they
didn't exist in the 18th hours well like
I said I think the whole thing too about
spontaneous human combustion one I think
the temperance movement wanted to kind
of play up this Oh drunks bursting into
flames to get people to stop drinking
and you know also there might have been
a little bit of God's judgment kind of
yeah oh hey don't be a bad person or God
like pointed finger tattoo and said she
wants like the Baptist version of Thor's
hammer but yeah there was a you know
like he said there have been even up
until the 20th century you know there
were somewhat of a party and stuff like
that I think there was one and there was
one in England from the 30s and she was
coming down the stairs to a party in her
dress suddenly caught fire with no
apparent cause it says so I don't know
yeah they they wore flammable materials
and you slam right eyes and yeah static
electricity you know yeah gauzy material
[ __ ] bark yeah because here's the
thing it's like human bodies are not
particularly combustible but clothing
sure as [ __ ] is so particular types of
clothing and and if you have particular
types of clothing with particular type
of chemicals on them and then you can
cause like a chemical reaction to take
place it does happen people of today are
little more scientifically educated so
we're I see a spark from static
electricity
set someone's dress on fire that's how
we interpret it yeah how many from 18
homers made out of turf with that the
same yeah if they just breezed into
flying yeah you know which is
technically true she did burst into
flames but not mysteriously okay so one
actually probably one of the most famous
cases and this is probably the one that
comes up the most like whenever you're
discussing spontaneous human combustion
happened in 1951 in st. Petersburg
Florida as it happens which is not that
far from us her name was Mary reser and
she was 67 years old she had just been
sitting in her living room as most of
these victims are and I guess her
landlady came to the house the next day
cuz no one heard from her stuff like
that no her landlady touched the
doorknob and the doorknob was super
super hot okay so she like freaked out
and she went got the police or whatever
and when the police came in they found
Mary reser and she there was she was
just basically a pile of ash now hers is
one of the cases where it said that her
skull was shrunk to the size of a teacup
quote-unquote nothing and like I said
this is something that's this is weird
to me because I don't see how the skull
could shrink that much I mean yeah the
fires are really
and stuff like that but this shrunken
skull thing is something that has come
up like I said it's in this case and at
least one other one where people said oh
the skull looked weirdly small yeah
which I don't see how that could happen
so I don't know yeah so I don't think
maybe she just had a really small head I
don't know to begin with and then people
were just like oh look how small the
skull is maybe if you heat a bone at the
right temperature for long enough maybe
you can kind of I wouldn't I wouldn't
think that it would shrink dehydrated
shrink up see I wouldn't think that
either I mean cuz normally what happens
if you heat up a bone you know to a
really high it'll just kind of flake
yeah you know it won't like shrink or
anything like that really it just kind
of turns white and gets sort of you know
it's just problematic witness testimony
it might be but like I said that is
something that's reported in a couple
different may be when you see a person
and they have flesh on their skull and
they have a big hairdo and then when you
burn that person's head down nothing to
the skull seems it seems much smaller
yeah maybe she had big hair I don't know
although there I you know I have seen a
picture of her when she was still alive
her hair didn't look totally big but you
know but so yeah maybe it was an optical
illusion she had basically burned she
had there was I think there was one leg
left with and it still had a slipper on
it the slipper heavy burned and when
they went in there they discovered the
fire had been about 3,500 degrees which
is actually hotter than a that should be
hot enough to just ignite the walls of
the room right but the weird thing is
that the most of the house wasn't burned
the only area that was burned I mean the
chair that she was sitting in obviously
was burned and there were a couple
things around her that were burned but
that was about it as far as proof it
didn't really spread and here is another
case where you know she was an older
lady she was 67 she had some she was a
smoker she had some kind of health
problems she wasn't real mobile she was
kind of overweight and she also took
sleeping pills so they kind of feel like
maybe what happened was that she was
smoking a cigarette she had taken
because her son had been over at the
house the night before and she said oh I
took a couple seeking all that she was
on seek at all and she said I'll take a
couple more for I go to bed so they
think maybe she took a couple sleeping
pills she was smoking in her chair
and then she fell asleep and the
cigarette fell on her and caught her on
fire I want to say to like I'm gonna go
into like a couple more cases but the
thing about how hot the fire burns and
how it doesn't ignite any of the rest of
the room is weird but if you see like
recreations because people have been
doing recreations to try to find out
like why why this looks this particular
way and it's not as strange as it seems
from the outset because usually what
will happen and like I said it's it's
not something that's coming from inside
the person it's usually because it's
almost always somebody that smokes or
it's almost always somebody that's
sitting by a fireplace or something like
that so what will end up happening is
that you know the cigarette or whatever
will ignite their clothes and usually
they're drunk or they're on sleeping
pills or something like that so they're
sleeping and they don't realize until
they wake up and it's too late and they
can't move and then the fire will pretty
much it'll burn through their clothes
it'll burn all their fat and the fire
will just goes like straight up in a
column rather than spreading out to the
side which is why things that are right
next to the people because sometimes
there's like really flammable [ __ ] like
right next to the people like newspapers
and curtains and stuff like that that
don't catch fire but the fire will go up
in a column and sometimes it'll spread
out over the ceiling so it'll make the
whole house hot because sometimes things
in other rooms will be melted but that's
because you know heat rises and then you
know sometimes the windows will turn
black they'll be condensation all over
the windows which is you know the
person's the water in their body like
coming out and drying up and it'll be on
the windows you know it looks strange
but there's it's not really as weird as
it looks
and even though firefighters will say
yet what's really weird I never saw
anything like that yet it is weird it's
rare it doesn't usually happen like that
in that type of situation but once you
see a reenactment of it it's not as
mysterious as as it looks you know what
I mean actually let's take a break right
now and then we come back I want to talk
about some more cases and I also want to
talk about this really awesome this is
really awesome documentary
about spontaneous human combustion I'll
put a link to anything cuz it's like
it's so epic and I you know and I just
really want to give it so it's from a
few years ago it is reference yeah
explains I loved it so much it was so
fun
alright so we're gonna take a break
right now and we'll be back in just a
few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
hey 13 o'clock fans love the show but
don't have an hour to spare check out
our new list channel 13 o'clock in
minutes all the fun creepy topics of the
main podcast but in easy to swallow
bite-sized pieces
links in the description more videos to
come soon
[Music]
okay we're back talking about
spontaneous combustion now another case
that was actually quite famous happened
in 1966 this was also an old man he was
92 and he was on a walker and no one
really knows what happened to him but
the meter reader came to his house and
let himself into the basement to read
the meter like he usually did and he
says that he goes in the house and he's
like he smelled something yeah I don't
know yeah I don't think he didn't go
that far as I say he said it was like a
very sweet smell yeah yeah I was like oh
like pork barbeque yeah you guys yeah he
said there was a he said it was a
sickening sweet odor okay
so he looks up and he sees a whole burke
through the floor so he goes up there to
investigate he finds in the bathroom
which i think was on the first or second
floor there's a hole burned in the floor
there's a walker like an aluminum walker
like perched over this hole and then
right by the hole is a leg like this
aliens can you imagine I just never want
to go to anybody's house if they don't
answer the department coz that's like
the worst thing you don't ever want to
find like just a pile of ashes you know
like [ __ ] Mars Attacks sabji with a
death ray there's just like a little boy
that walker he's just terracing with
that walker and also just poof yeah like
I said that's what it seems like that
seems like yeah and it's like what
dangling with just one foot there that's
not burned and it's oh my god that's
horrible
okay so the other there's another case
to that and this one like weirded me out
right this one happened in 1986 and this
guy the victims name is George Mott and
ironically he had been a firefighter
okay yeah but he was retired and he had
some health problems he had like
problems breathing and stuff like that
so he was on like an oxygen machine or
whatever not always but he had one in
his in his room that helped him sleep in
his boat he used to but he had quit I
mean his son said he didn't smoke
anymore because you know because
cigarettes no because his because he'd
had lung problems and he was on oxygen
so there so he had quit smoking
evidently but the firefighters who
investigated this and there are pictures
of it I'll put some of them in the in
the video but they found it was
basically his bed was just this huge
square of ash you couldn't tell that
there was a body on there and he said
when we walked in we didn't know that
there was a body because you couldn't
they had to like draw a little outline
like this is kind of where his head
wasn't something like that and the bed
had burned and it had burned like
partially through the floor now
the thing that was weirdest about this
like nothing else in the bedroom was
really burned the TV that was across the
room had melted like the plastic case
had melted next to him there was his
little oxygen machine which had a
canister of long matches on top of it
which had not ignited which seemed very
weird
however a couple rooms away inside the
refrigerator the butter and the plastic
butter dish were melted huh and there
were hotdogs inside of a package in the
refrigerator that it cooked weird how
far was the frigerator I don't know how
far away it was but it was like a room
or two away isn't that weird are they
positive that the two that it's related
to the human combustion yeah there had
been a fire in the apartment maybe he
burnt those earlier no they were still
inside the package they were still
inside the package they had boiled
inside the package and the butter and
the butter dish were melted inside the
refrigerator yeah that's yeah like I
thought that weirded me out like more
than the well like I said what must have
had
was that it got so hot in the because
the fire will consume all the oxygen and
stuff like that and if the house is all
closed in and doesn't really have
anywhere to go then the inside of the
house will get really really hot yeah
maybe some vacuum has created some yeah
although it seemed weird that the
matches that were like right next to his
bed didn't ignite spontaneously because
those are flames may have something to
do with air currents it built up inside
of a house because of the fire
yeah air around yeah and his save me a
wind action like a convection that's
what I was thinking it must have been
something like that but I was like
totally weirded out by but like I was
saying before you know if the if the
fire goes up in a column then it'll
travel from room to room up on the
ceiling yeah without really igniting
anything along the walls or anything
like that that like I don't know for
some reason the cooked hotdogs are the
refrigerator that weird when I was
looking at that I was like holy [ __ ]
but yeah so same kind of thing happened
there was one in Abbeville in South
Wales which it's funny who's it I saw I
saw it on a documentary and it happened
in Blackwood and I'm like hey I've been
there cuz I used to live in Wales
I still live right by there like I think
I know where that Street is actually but
he was like he I thought he was like
kind of a younger guy I thought now he
was an older guy 273 but he was in his
kitchen and all of a sudden bursts into
flame and all that's left of him and
like I said this picture is pretty gross
there's like nothing the Earth's just
like ash and then there's like just legs
with tennis shoes yeah like just laying
in the kitchen and nothing else is
burned the kitchen is totally clean
right but the thing is I mean he was
right next to the gas stove so that
might have that might have had to do
with it now there was another one that
happened a lot these are in England I
wonder why I mean not that not the Mary
Rees or one that was in Florida but a
lot of these are in England for some
reason they drink they smoke a lot move
there's gas
yeah maybe and all the years yeah
because you know densely packed towns
and cities true high population density
so you're gonna have a greater chance of
it happening yeah it's close animals and
things like all right yeah okay
yeah because this one here now it's
actually very rare in cases of human
combustion for someone to see it happen
obviously because usually for a body to
burn up to that
it usually takes a long time so normally
what would happen is that the person
would catch on fire and basically like
smolder or like cook down to nothing
over the course of several hours yeah
without anyone being aware creations of
how this is probably happening it's not
as impressive as you think
right but like I said in general it
takes a long time now there there was
one case and it's kind of controversial
but there was one case it was similar to
the married research kind of case it was
an older woman she was a smoker she was
sitting in her chair and burned up and
all that was left of her was her legs
from the knee down but she was still on
them everything else was just burned and
the chair was burned but nothing next to
her was burned now apparently this
happened in 21 minutes because her
granddaughter had been in the house and
she sent her granddaughter down to the
store to get cigarettes and her
granddaughter was gone for about 20
minutes and then when she came back the
house was all hot and stuff like that so
unless the witness accounts are wrong
because normally like I said for a body
to have been burned to that extent it
would normally take a long time like
five six seven eight hours we're talking
about right and we actually described
what it what it actually looks like
during the recreation well I was gonna
get to that because I was gonna talk
about that really fun documentary and
and they did a recreation on there but
they've done other ones also um Joe
Nickell did one and other people have
done one why the means that we were just
talking about can a body burn up with 20
minutes after I say no yeah see that's
the only thing that bothers me about
that was some kind of an accelerant to
help the process of it yeah I mean they
didn't find one but like I said it could
be that the witnesses were mistaken or
you see how the woman died right yeah
she had a bottle of rubbing alcohol on
her hand and that helped yeah she had
some perfume or something like that yes
hairspray something like that yeah
because honestly there was one case and
this also happened in England I think it
was in the 80s and this was actually
witnessed by some people she was it was
that it was on a college campus and she
was walking with a couple of her friends
and she was just walking from class to
class and suddenly burst into flames and
several
boss office yeah you know so some
witnesses jump to try to help her out
and stuff like that but she did later
died from her injuries but what that
could have been that could have been
maybe she was wearing a sweater that was
like generating some static electricity
she had just sprayed hair spray like in
the bathroom a few minutes before and it
kind of reacted with that etc I remember
when I was a kid there were still closed
in circulation that were highly
flammable oh yeah we're enough and
people today just take it for granted
that your clothes don't catch on fire
there was stuff out there that they were
selling on the open market that you got
to round up the flame you just go up
like gasoline yeah but they don't make
that anymore
well for good reason yeah now another
one that was witnessed this happened in
1982 and there was a woman named Jeannie
Safin now she was um mentally
handicapped and she was evidently
sitting in the kitchen with her father I
remember he says that she was just
sitting there doing nothing and he saw a
flash of light and then her upper body
was enveloped in flames and that there
was like flames coming out of her mouth
he said it looked like a dragon yeah I
remember that story right
she likes survived she didn't scream or
she didn't seem to be in any pain or
anything like that but how bad were her
burns uh bad enough to kill her I mean
she she didn't die right away but they
took her to the hospital obviously and
she went into a coma and she died
shortly afterward I think it was a week
later now this one it kind of seems like
the family is saying they think it came
from within her because they didn't see
anything yeah but see I don't know I'm
the Sienna baila like they're convinced
because they saw I saw an interview with
the dad or you know or with one of the
witnesses could it have been a murder
yeah that's something you have to
consider yeah that's what I mean you
know I'm not gonna say that because they
seemed like nice people but you know
what I mean honestly I think I mean she
wasn't a smoker but her dad smoked a
pipe so you know people were thinking
well maybe he you know hit the pipe and
like an ember flew out of it and got on
her clothes or something like that it's
there's so many things it's just like
caught on her clothes caught on fire
probably and it surprised them so badly
that they remembered it being more
impressive than it really was
yeah because honestly what breathing
fire out of erm yeah I just looked that
way we'll see what could happen and it
can they were yeah what could happen is
that I mean if your clothes caught on
fire up by your face you start to
hyperventilate because you'd be scared
so it would look like the flames were
coming in or out I would think right I
mean so maybe that's all it was cuz if
they didn't see it actually happened and
they just glanced over it to say but
like I said it's just like every other
kind of quote-unquote paranormal type of
thing it's like there's so many other
things it could be right I remember that
story though yeah and then there was
another one and this also happened now
this one was kind of weird too this was
happened in 1967 it is also in England
and there was a woman and she was riding
a bus and she looked out the window and
saw like a blue flame like a gas jet so
she called the cops and they found a bum
who was like laying in a stairway and
his stomach was like split open and
there was like blue which that's pretty
weird and the guy they interviewed the
guy that found the body like I saw like
an older man who died or he lived the
the bomb he died yet okay you know
exactly did he die of burns I guess
could it have been somebody stabbed that
bomb alright and that yeah and he was he
was a smoker yeah same time and he
caught his clothing on fire and his
intestinal gases burnt yeah heard
through the sack better bet you have
wood you don't yeah maybe he somebody
stabbed him I didn't think of that but
yeah because the guy that found him was
like it sounded just like a gas jet you
got this methane and you body yeah oh
and I want to get to that too because
Bruce Dickinson did a very very funny
yeah he didn't light a fart did it I
don't want to ruin it for you I want you
to see it okay
methane may have been involved in a stab
wound it may be yeah I didn't even think
about a stab wound but yeah it could be
because he was fighting over [ __ ] yeah
maybe they were just fighting I mean
because they made much of the fact that
oh he was a drunk and they found like a
big bottle of alcohol and I some and
stuff like that try fighting over that
booze maybe yeah maybe
No yeah but the problem here is people
who want to make this a paranormal thing
there's this one guy and he's probably
the most famous like spontaneous human
combustion researcher in the paranormal
vein and his name is Larry Arnold and he
wrote a book called
ablaze and he described I think there's
thirty different cases in there that he
described he thinks that the fire is
coming from inside the person and he
posits that there is a subatomic
particle heretofore unknown to science
called a pirate Ron and that this yeah
and that this pirate Ron is interacting
with other subatomic particles in your
body where is this and causing you to
catch fire where is this on the periodic
table yeah what he's saying he well he
wants to be the one that's like
discovered and stuff like that and he
here's the thing yeah so there's like I
said pretty much every documentary about
spontaneous human combustion has this
guy on it it's because he like wrote the
book on the paranormal it kind of thing
and he seems a little bad or now he
seems a little like that seems like a
very straight like I said it's not crazy
to think that there's some kind of
chemical reaction because check it out
okay if you take a rag and soak it in
linseed oil and you sit it out in the
Sun for several hours it will catch fire
okay without a spark or anything like
that just because of the chemical
reaction will make enough heat to catch
fire so it's not crazy to think that it
could be a chemical reaction inside the
body but very unusual circumstances
would have to be present and normally
like I said because the human body is
not particularly flammable you would
have to have some kind of accelerant you
would have to have some kind of spark
from somewhere for that to happen you
know what I mean and because it just it
doesn't seem like it would happen
spontaneously unless you would eaten
something for you know what I mean and
then drop the cigarette on yourself or
something like that it's gonna be
something to kick it off right there has
to be something to kick it off that's
what I'm saying because people that work
in funeral homes and cemeteries and
stuff like that will tell you it's very
very hard yeah to burn a body so now I
wanted to talk about and this is so this
is so [ __ ] funny and I found this
like I watched all these documentaries
about spontaneous combustion and they
were you know there was what History
Channel one there was a Discovery
Channel or whatever and then I came
across this one that was hosted by Bruce
Dickinson from Iron Maiden yeah and I
was like Renaissance man by the way yeah
yeah he totally is yeah and it was from
2006 and it was it aired on Sky one in
the UK and I was like how funny that
Bruce Dickinson did a show about
spontaneous human combustion and the
funniest thing about it too is that I
was kind of hoping when I saw it I was
like ooh maybe he has like a whole like
Mythbusters Joe Rogan type series that
he hosted cuz I would watch the [ __ ] out
of that but you know what's weird
spontaneous human combustion that's the
only one just that one like he's been on
other TV show like he was on quiz shows
and he did one about like Aeronautics
and stuff like that yeah but for some
reason spontaneous human combustion that
was like the only paranormal type
documentary he did and if you guys I'll
put a link in the description somebody
somebody uploaded it to YouTube like in
five parts or something like that cuz
it's like 45 minutes and it is like it
is delightful okay and he well he
explores pretty bit like he is a skeptic
he doesn't think it's a paranormal
phenomenon so he kind of goes and
experiments with all these different
things and he makes a lot of good points
on here you know they're very funnily
presented he's like okay for one thing
there's a lot of things that could spark
it that you wouldn't necessarily see I
mean obviously a lot of these ones was
like these old people in their chairs or
something like that you know they were
smokers they had an oxygen machine they
were sitting by an open fireplace which
you know an ember could have shot out or
whatever you know so there's that he's
like also there's static electricity
depending on what you were wearing or
what your if you were walking across a
carpet or something like that and that
he showed part of a youtube video where
there was a lady and she was getting gas
at a gas station and she yeah and she
got back in her car and then she gets
back and touches
the pump and a big fireball comes out I
mean she was okay because she moved but
I mean [ __ ] even the gas pump every
single gas pump I've ever seen has a
little warning sign on there it says
please you know discharge your static
electricity before you touch because you
could blow up yeah you know what I mean
it doesn't happen very often but it
can't happen
and it doesn't really take that much of
a spark because he wanted to he wanted
to show he was talking about the case I
mentioned earlier about the college girl
that caught on fire between classes so
he had a sweater of the type you know
sorted that she was wearing heard
somebody would have been wearing in the
at that time period that was kind of
fuzzy and he's like now I'm gonna spray
hairspray on it and now I'm gonna do
like a little bit of a static charge on
it and shoot it went right it on fire so
he's like you know that can't happen
he's like also you get struck by
lightning there's also ball lightning
which you know that's kind of an iffy
proposition but it does exist and they
and actually I don't remember if it was
on that documentary up there or if there
was another one where apparently some
ball lightning came in a [ __ ] window
or came down a chimney and knocked the
guy back and then kind of you know went
through the room and like out the window
and like the guy they showed pictures
the guy had like burns like all over his
back and [ __ ] I'm suspicious of ball
lightning until I read a book written by
a German u-boat commander in World War 2
yeah and he mentions it he said they
documented it many times over in the
fleet when they would switch from diesel
engine over to the batteries yeah had a
huge manual switch and during that
switching process every now and then
ball of lightning would jump out and go
through decks the the German Navy knew
all about it
yeah and they had recorded it many many
times and I'm just not gonna call I'm
gonna call [ __ ] on sure no I'm just
saying that it's as always DC power yeah
and always some kind of big exposed
switch yeah with lots of current you
know lots of voltage yeah I know it does
it does happen I know we use AC current
in our homes so we don't say you don't
see you don't see well I mean they on
the Bruce Dickinson show he got a guy
that was like trying to make like a
small ball lighting by putting like some
kind of steel it's been like in a
microwave to try to get enough
microwaves going to get some plasma
like that and it did kind of make a
little bit of a thing and then the
microwave look so which is very funny
because Bruce Dickinson is standing
there going um is this gonna block
should I even be standing here okay now
so he also and this was the most
wonderful part of the show when he was
talking about well could you like fart
yourself on fire and he talked to this
old guy the scientist and he's like what
a potty old British scientist and he
said he's like this guy believes in
essentially self-lighting farts right
he's like if you eat a diet that's very
high in phosphorous egg yolks beans all
that type of stuff
beat the British wheat beans for
breakfast they do that with eggs yeah
there you go
it's beans on toast yeah beans on maybe
that's why it happens so much canned
beans for breakfast you guys are insane
it just makes the toast all soggy I
don't really hit I don't like soggy
toast that's all girls but um and they
don't even like peanut butter yeah I
don't get any peanut butter is wonderful
actually it's not as good as cashew
butter or almond butter but the butter
is pretty damn good but yeah so this guy
is basically like if you have a Brit a
very high phosphorus diet and you kind
of eat a lot of stuff that causes a lot
of gas and stuff like that and then he's
like you still need some kind of a spark
you know what I mean but he's like it is
theoretically possible so that you could
fart and set yourself on fire and the
funniest thing too is that he they did
it with they took a blow-up doll like
sex - ha ha ha and they filled her full
of methane yeah and methane as they say
over there they filled her up with
little packets full of methane and then
they put a little bit of water cuz some
there was this particular chemical it
looked like little rocks I can't
remember what it was some kind of
phosphate and if you add water to it and
then air it will ignite so SIF is for
sex all they had like stuffed with all
this meth little bags and methane and
stuff like that and then they put like a
couple these crystals like in her butt
crack or something like that and then
like got it wet it's just
she just like she burns nothing like
very briefly so you know be careful when
they did like a hole they did like a
hole fart segment which was really the
best part cuz seeing Bruce Dickinson
talking about farting and making fart
noises and telling you pull my finger
and stuff like that it's just it amused
the [ __ ]
yes Oh farting that could do it too and
also there's also um some people think
that if you eat like a really low fat
diet or your where your body's going
undergoing um ketosis like some people
do on that [ __ ] Atkins diet or
whatever it is then your body will
produce too much acetone which
theoretically is supposed to be able to
also make you ignite which I don't know
if I buy it like I said but these are
all also contingent upon there being a
spark all right really I mean you have
to have something that's gonna react
with you know what I mean now at the end
of the documentary and at the end of the
couple of other documentaries about
spontaneous human combustion they will
tell you about the wick effect yeah this
is what I think it is yeah
so they're basically okay so like a
human being they're like is like an
inside-out candle like a candle they
used to make them from animal that but
the wick was in the middle they said now
a human is made of fat with clothing on
the outside so you have the wick on the
outside and what they will usually do
though say okay now check this out
they'll take like a pork shoulder or
something like that and they'll wrap it
in cotton and then set it on fire
now what ended what ends up happening is
that the clothing will kind of just
smolder and turn black it won't like
ignite really but the fire will kind of
go into the middle and it'll start
melting all the fat which will ignite
and it also it makes the fire burn low
and slow but very very very hot and it
usually will keep running until all the
fat is burned off you kind of see if
when you're barbecuing meat yeah
especially suddenly something's real
fatty like sausage yeah they start to
plump up of course you know the juices
from the meat start coming out yeah and
it gets on the grill and if it's hot
enough it just kind of spontaneously
combusted burns like a candle yeah right
there next to the sausage as soon as you
have a roll
sausages inside turn it turn the flame
down a little bit right now and I've
seen videos of those take a whole pig
yep and wrap it up in clothing like a
jacket or pants you know something like
that and they have it sitting on a
carpet and they just take a lighter yeah
and just put a little bit of fire on it
and it will sit there and just burn low
and slow and using its own fat juices
yeah and it'll just cut wick on the
clothes will act like a wick it'll just
burn for hours and hours yeah and the
flames never get big yeah it basically
stays pretty slow pretty low rather
explains a lot of what it really does
because the fire will usually stay
contained like usually the bed will burn
you know the body will burn down to
nothing usually the the reason why the
extremities don't usually burn like the
feet stuff is because there's not much
fat on your feet or your hands or
whatever and it's away from the main
body the fire too yeah you know cuz your
abdomen is kind of where all your body
fat is so that's where most of the
feeling gets all [ __ ] yeah usually the
ceiling will turn black but but like I
said fire tends to go up like in a
column so you know it will go across the
ceiling it will produce heat which can
melt things in other parts of the house
but it won't necessarily ignite yeah the
room anything else the room becomes like
an oven yeah like a convection and right
and you know things that are plastic
across the side you know on the other
side yeah but nothing ever bursts into
flames
not usually even things you'd think
would like I said like the case with
George MOT what the matches you think
that's what if that's what I think it is
and I don't think that they're dying
from the flames they're dying a heart
attacks and dropping a cigarette yeah
and then they drop so they might already
be dead or they're so because I think a
lot of times I think the reason why so
many of them like they mentioned that so
many of them are drunks it's not because
alcohol is particularly flammable
because alcohol is flammable but it
burns at a very low temperature an
alcohol fire doesn't produce enough heat
to cause the type of bodily destruction
that you see in these cases so I think
the only reason that alcohol is a factor
is because maybe these people are so
drunk that they catch themselves on fire
and they're just like past hour blacked
out but think of pain from
turn up or wake them up you would think
that what they're drinkers they're not
all that healthy they're slipping off
and they're dying there's yeah into a
coma and maybe they drop a cigarette on
the bedclothes and some of the smoke
from the sheets and the bed itself they
inhale it that takes them out right
there so smoke inhalation kills yeah
because it doesn't take very long to die
from SIA inhalation and then they burn
up yeah because smoke inhalation is is
painless yeah and yeah honestly I don't
think they're like burning alive or
anything like that I mean they would
normally have to be dead because the
second you caught fire if you were awake
even if you were sleeping the second you
caught fire you'd be like oh [ __ ] and
you'd wake up and try to put it out
they're not dead when they're burning up
they're dying yeah they're not aware of
it yeah and I should say on the on the
Bruce Dickinson documentary they did the
thing where they had he they had like a
big room and they had it done you know
like a fireproof room or whatever and
they had it all done up like a little
bedroom
they had a pig and they put it in the
bed and they put blankets over and stuff
like that they just caught it on fire
now they let it burn for several hours
now
here's the thing and I feel like a lot
of people that are kind of invested in
it being a paranormal phenomenon kind of
picked up on this because I noticed in
the YouTube comments people were like
yeah but you know what I mean because
what ended up happening for the first
few hours like the first two or three
hours it did look exactly like a
spontaneous combustion type of thing
like nothing else in the room ignited
the pig was burning like kind of low it
was really hot in there and stuff like
that however after several hours the
fire got much bigger raw and it blew out
the windows of the chamber which meant
all this oxygen came rushing in made the
fire enormous it burned it melted the
camera that was filming the inside of
the thing it just burned everything out
thing is though is it that probably
happens most of the time you just know
that as a fire as a house fire yeah it
wouldn't be weird
yeah the spontaneous human combustion
cases are the fires that don't do them
that don't do that that are enclosed
that the windows don't bust open so they
don't get any more oxygen so they just
like burn down
Stickley more rare and when you see it
you're like to have you know yeah
spontaneous human combustion because
even people that write about it as a
paranormal phenomenon even they will
admit that you know there's only been
like 200 documented cases like it's very
onion it's an unusual thing to happen
and I think that's why people want to
attribute something mysterious to it but
I don't think it's necessarily as
serious the size of the flames the speed
of the fire which is burns it's all
gonna be dictated by how much oxygen is
available how big is the room are there
windows in the room just things like
that yeah how fat is this person yeah
there's a lot of you know a lot of
different factors it could be that in
certain cases the flames will be very
low and very slow burning because of the
lack of oxygen in the room and it just
sits there just kind of cooks yeah and
then it burns herself out the editor
it's discovered you're like wow what is
that yeah it's a legs other slightly
normal is under slightly more common
circumstances it just would have been a
house fire the whole house would have
burned down yeah and like I said that's
usually contingent upon the fire
operating in such a way that I mean if
the house is enclosed yeah it would
happen like on the Bruce Dickinson
documentary where the windows would bust
out and then all this new oxygen would
rush in and feed the fire and then the
whole house would burn down and no one
would even be talking about it as a
spontaneous human combustion case one of
the cases I remembered that was labeled
spontaneous human combustion turned out
to be a murder also yeah found a woman
near her front door it looked like
spontaneous human combustion but they
know that she was murdered turns out
what happened is the guy killed her and
then took perfume from the bathroom yeah
and sprinkled it on her and set her on
fire while she was sitting on just a
small rug and the end result was exactly
what he would see at a spontaneous human
combustion yeah so there was just like a
leg left and yes like that right but you
know the guy created spontaneous human
combustion nothing with just a bottle
Perkins yeah and like I said I feel like
you know I feel like if this was an
actual chemical reaction that could
happen inside a person yeah then it
would happen more often and like you
said I think the fact
I think the only fact that the reason
why people think it's weird or
mysterious or anything like that because
it looks funny I mean you would expect
you know a fire it burns up everything
you know it looks funny just like a
little pile of ashes a leg and nothing
else really burned in the house so I can
see why people would think that there
was some kind of supernatural aspect to
it if you didn't see it happen yeah very
unlikely when you see the recreations of
it you go oh it's that okay yes that's
when you see it and the recreation with
the pig carcasses and various things
have been done many many times and they
almost always look almost exactly --vs
the little pig feet sometimes it leaves
the head and just the middle of it's all
burned out and nothing else in the room
burned like I said the only reason that
the that the one on the Bruce Dickinson
Show burned the whole room up was
because the windows rusted out which
doesn't usually happen but because when
people come in to like when firefighters
come in to these you know spontaneous
human combustion cases they'll say you
know the windows are black and covered
with water you know from the body yeah
but yeah but it didn't bust out which is
the reason why nobody smelled it or
nobody called it or anything like that
it's just like you said it makes turn
into a house fire why it didn't turn
into a house fire because it couldn't
get any more oxygen and once it burned
its fuel up which was the human fat
that's getting oxygen but getting it
through the cracks underneath the door
so because it's a small amount of oxygen
coming in the flames never really get
that big yeah I mean there have to be a
particular set of circumstances for it
to turn out like that and they are very
unusual circumstances which is why
people comment on them but like you said
in most cases if you dropped a cigarette
on yourself and you were you know
knocked out or whatever then your house
would just burn down and you would just
be burnt I'm pretty convinced that most
of the time when cigarettes are involved
that person dies they die of a heart
attack the cigarette falls out of their
hand it starts to fire right on them or
next to them a living person's good yeah
cuz like I said if you were awake or
aware of your surroundings you would
immediately like start to put it out I
mean even if you weren't entirely
successful
so you know I don't think like I said
the pictures look weird and the gross
and stuff like
but I don't think there's anything I
don't think a person can spontaneously
ignite unless there are very specific
circumstances very specific
circumstances and you know and you're
not gonna have a scene that looks like
they're just two feet yeah four person
spontaneously combusts it's gonna look
like somebody that gasoline poured on
them and they catch on fire they burn
for a few seconds then it goes out yeah
then you have a body there with
third-degree burns on or segregate burns
yeah because I've seen these somewhere
it smolders with burns for hours yeah
cuz like I said firefighter just tell
you when they pull a body out of a house
fire even a horrible bad yeah it looks
like a person just shard a chart person
it doesn't look like just two feet and a
pile of ashes right all right so we're
getting to the end of the show yeah so
we would like to remind everybody once
again to please go to our patreon page
www patreons 13 o'clock yes thank you to
all our new patrons hooray and like I
said if you're a twenty dollar nut
patron you should be getting some free
stuff in the mail if you haven't gotten
it already and also if you go to our
blog 13 o'clock podcast wordpress.com I
think I got it right that time there is
also a link to PayPal if you would
rather just do a one time donation
rather than a monthly donation no kind
of cool sure you can do that yeah also
go to wgal.com slash their ten o'clock
podcast and check out our show the links
in the description yeah I put all the
links there usually and you know if you
like the show please like us on facebook
follow us on twitter subscribe and all
the other stuff and I think that's about
it right yes
oh and look out for my new book the
faceless villain will Cho be out in a
couple of weeks yeah and when the
audiobook is up let me know if you want
a free copy and I'll get you one yeah
so until next Tuesday bye
[Music]
you desire
[Music]
Oh
you
[Music]
you